by the way you have you done the
gathering of the judges i've done it
nine times
i have tripped acid all nine times i was
there the year they threw [ __ ] at tila
tequila i was there it was awesome it
was so incredible it was the greatest
moment ever she got on stage and they
started booing her and then she just
like
leaned into it like pulls her top off
and starts shaking her titties and like
she thought like juggalos would be like
oh well no we're gonna cheer for that
these are juggalos [ __ ]
everybody out here shaking their titties
and [ __ ] smells like my pecker it's
[ __ ] you know i'm saying
not because i'm a juggalo at heart not
because juggalos think but because
they've been camping for five days in
the woods in [ __ ] 80 to 98 degree
weather and doing drugs listen right and
you're shaking your attention they just
start throwing just bottles of [ __ ] and
piss at her
i'd like to point out i haven't met many
juggalos that i've came away from being
around and said they smell nice yeah
well listen i've got some of the best
drugs and weed on earth i can tell you
this
if i have a car oh sorry about that just
pop it right on i've been [ __ ] with
this to the point i was trapping trying
to break it just take it off yeah no i
want to plug the cash you know
i might have did it though there we go
[ __ ] let's go son
if i break down on the side of the road
and i see a car pull up with that
hatching man oh you're good
thank you the most
genuine people that's why i said i'll
always be a juggle load heart those
people are the best people on earth and
you want to get good acid
you call a [ __ ] juggalo if you don't
call a dude that's a [ __ ] deadhead
if you got to either have
a teddy bear tattooed on you or a
hatchet man tattooed on you to give me
any psychedelic except for you kev it's
literally it's so funny
there's like teachers now with like
hatchet man tattoos and [ __ ] oh yeah for
sure that we're just tripping balls
watching tia tequila get sh absolutely
swimming [ __ ] big old janko pants
[ __ ] great malinko jerseys yeah oh
yeah just [ __ ] you know remember
those jinkos oh yeah you had a pair you
meant no i know but you never had a pair
of shoes my cousin was a big juggler i'm
guilty i had a pair of jeans do you
remember like the bottom of them how
like how crusty they'd get because they
dragged under your shoe oh my god i love
crusty stuff though you could probably
tell but you could put a whole two liter
in the pocket yeah oh you could put
anything listen yo yo this is the
advantage of being fat i have this
pocket right here in my denim jackets i
can put a bottle of tequila in smuggle
it anywhere wow true story i am always i
normally have a bottle of tequila on me
when you were at the liquor store
earlier i thought that's what you were
getting so i didn't bring any no i had
to get water oh
is there was there a drug bridge at the
gathering yeah it was the best bridge
ever so so there's like so at the
gathering of the juggalos i don't know
if it still is the case i gotta take you
but there's a
supposedly like a free drug bridge or
some [ __ ] right and i heard there's like
a [ __ ] hut
dude it's a community
[ __ ] fast wonder what that smells
like in there though the [ __ ] huh well
i have a reference point
but it's just
did you ever [ __ ] the [ __ ] out at uh
the gathering i've never [ __ ] in the
[ __ ] hut at the gathering you're [ __ ]
i [ __ ] at the gathering nice the
gathering [ __ ] it is awesome yeah it
will change listen so they used to have
a cave and rock illinois the only way to
get there was during the day by ferry
you had to take a ferry or you had to
drive like four hours around the other
way to get there or you could take a
ferry over
it was on private property so they could
do anything anything it was a complete
[ __ ] chaos it was absolute
lawlessness
you know what the same thing of the
gathering is
mud parks i play mud parks all the time
these festivals these off-road atv parks
they're the gathering for country people
they go out there and camp for four days
and [ __ ] it's lawless they do drugs
they [ __ ]
they [ __ ] drink themselves to sleep
they catch [ __ ] on fire and they ride
[ __ ] four wheelers it is heaven on
earth it is the best experience i've
ever every time i play one i pull up
early i have somebody bring the four
wheelers out we tear [ __ ] up it is a
blast the gathering's the exact same way
it's just like it's like
everybody's there for the music and
peace you don't hear people arguing
right
it's like a family-oriented fan base
right yeah for sure no there that's
their whole thing is family yeah it's a
dude i'll take you to one they're a ball
i tried to play this one this year but i
had a scheduling i've been to a
few shows yeah where they shoot faygo
into the crowd yeah yeah that's like the
show they do it the last night too but
they did a they did a tour
tech nine
cottonmouth kings and bones that was one
of the biggest tourists ever own things
in harmony yes what a [ __ ] i saw them
at mesa what was the name of this we had
a crazy name too yeah it was like really
big they did mesa amphitheater which is
like six thousand people sold out and
they were [ __ ] launching two leaders
into the sky of faygo you know how hard
it was to sell hard tickets back then
you couldn't like you had to advertise
like traditional ways true like i
remember word of mouth you know i used
to always get
i used to always just pick up a new
times which is like a free newspaper in
arizona and you just go in there and see
what shows that was the only way i knew
what shows were coming yeah now it's
like the internet i play yellow wolf has
a [ __ ] one of my favorite gathering
stories ever
they shot a bottle rocket while he was
performing
and he goes at this moment [ __ ] true
yellow or fashion he goes
which they wasn't shooting it like to be
mean it's just a gathering right they're
just [ __ ] off shooting fireworks and
he goes i bet you can't hit me with a
bottle rocket
dude
hundreds of juggalos just start shooting
bottle rockets and yellow wolf he's up
there like dude he's slipping them like
tyson in 84. he's
through moving boom they're whizzing by
he goes haha [ __ ] and he's
rapping while doing it it was like one
of the dopest things i've ever seen